what what's the real Jenelle it's thank
you yeah let's do some calculus video k
now they've got ahead and called it FX
sir i'm going to call it f dash I will
never ever used application of Popkin
that I'll just use this opportunity to
mention because some people are coming
show me this if you have please guys
down for reasons of the work if you have
something like this
so we know that when you differentiate a
log function right what pattern are we
going to get away and get ya f dash on
ya which we used to looking for that
when we integrate but here it's what
we're going to end up with so I
shouldn't be so there's no reason now be
that it's F natural f some people just
take that notation and I'll put it into
the next line so this is what they all
right okay now I chosen this particular
example to highlight to you how crazy
this is because you can see that's why I
just said it to you right that's meant
to be a dash right but that clearly does
not look like that what does that look
like hello little one because look in
this context of course it looks like a 1
i'm raising things to powers don't do
this don't ever do this like some people
right I mean maybe it would look less
crazy if I read something like this okay
it's like that's probably not a one
because it'd be a bit redundant to say
one but it's just such a such an overlap
yeah that's right it's always going to
be redundant but people you wouldn't
believe how many people will miss read
their own writing or under pressure be
like oh yeah what am I writing here or
it's just not clear to lamarca what's
going on okay if you can't just do the
chain rule on that if you insist on
doing something like this in at least
right now like better than to really
that's what that means we've got good
notation for that okay the only time
I'll use dash notation is over here okay
because they told me is so I'm just
going to run them okay there is one
other reason why it's dangerous to train
over rely on this which is what we've
been looking at chain rule so far and
we'll be integrating myself station and
so on we often have to take advantage of
this guy now when you're doing chain
rule or reverse chain rule like it
really really matters what you're
differentiating with respect you like
which variable am I looking at and of
course dash notation it's only built in
this world where it's like oh you're
only different
with respect to Y thing cuz that's
that's all there is in there okay but we
know we learned so much camulus that
sort of takes you away from there that's
why I try to avoid this notation America
bless you I'm only using a confession
forces all right now we're ready to do
this do we know how to videos of 10 of
us one on very good okay now when you
have a look at this next guy you're
going to have these chain more on this
right so what's the derivative of the
inside now if that guy is X to the
negative 1 right then the derivative of
that is just like every other folder i
will bring the power up front and we
reduce the power by one okay so i've got
negative 10 next web yep that's the dude
on the inside so i'm going to write that
straight away maybe one x square now
I've got to do the dream of the outside
which is just like this with one
difference yeah instead of an X there
it's our one on exactly inside functions
let's go ahead and we'll write that
there is the dirtiest I'm happy with
that okay you can see this is marvis
nice simplify that happens right for
starters we got this guy at the front
that becomes a minus sign but what
happens in here yeah very good what I
mean so I can figure this a couple of
knowledge in probably the easiest way is
to say this is what an x squared all
right i'm just going to multiply to my
denominators yeah so what's going to
happen is one over there's an x squared
there and then there's a plus one where
do you see that she's your other phone
cuz he get one yepper isn't that zero
yeah yeah it sure is so what does this
mean it's a poison yeah when you have a
gradient that's zero right that means
that you're careful it's rather than
saying it's a concert i'm going to say
you have a horizontal one you know
alone just going to be cautious with it
because this this is a weird theme right
I'm not just going to go ahead and say
it's a straight line okay but I know
that there's something horizontal about
it it's because the grades of 0 okay yes
it's odd it's odd so think about this
right what are we put just powerful
we're all still thinking on this right
so far I'm expecting a horizontal line
of some kind but I'm also expecting an
odd function yeah now this is kind of
weird but after I draw this but normally
normally a horizontal line can't be an
odd function normally right he's a
horizontal one is it matches my f dash x
equals 0 but it's not odd what kind of
symmetry it's either right and you can
put that horizontal line almost anywhere
and you'll get an even function not a
nun function if all you have is a single
horizontal line there is one horizontal
line that's also not function and I've
artfully dodged drawing it on my diagram
no no so it is anything that's the x
axis right that's enough we've but it is
an odd function because mia 0 is the
same as negative sir so that works is
that what this is no no reason it is a
discontinuity and so do with that a
second so how do I go about this now the
question sort of gives you a bit of a
head right but here I'm going to say you
know what it's not that desperate if
what I'm going to get is a horizontal
line I'm just going to try it out I
shouldn't be able to pick a value I like
and get a value out of this right so
what value would you like me to commit
how that x equals 1 but there is right
you already told me the tan inverse of 1
this pilot for right so if I say let it
sit with one then f of 1 is going to be
tan inverse of 1 is painful and then the
other guy is tan inverse of 10 bars what
is also terrible ok now we're ready to
actually draw ourselves a set of
activities and see what's going on in
their burrows the sooner we have to say
that we go yeah ok so let me just put
this point on here I can't we just put
the token so I'm just going to plot on x
equals let's just put it to you ok
there's a single point that I know I'm
going through ok now we've already
established that everywhere for x except
that point I should be fun I shouldn't
be fine and you can it's not that hard
to put it a couple more value this
gradient should be 0 over here and
there's no breaks apart from this
vertical and I should be able to go all
the way through here with a grading of 0
but then there's a break like my
function card existed but because I know
because it's one of the first things I
wrote down there's odd symmetry this
right over here and a quick buck
insertion of say X equal negative 1 and
verify this for you right you're not
going to continue up here like because
you're an odd function you have to come
down here and there's the rest of your
browser ok it's a very weird kind of a
picture right but it's inescapable when
you put together all of that it's a bit
like they're sort of showing your way
through this line what could possibly
match all of these properties that I've
seen before and that's what makes a good
agency question this is not a standard
type of graph this is PI on to appear
and negative PI 0 too long yup so as we
is against really but that's kind of the
weed interesting stuff happens like when
you combine these guys
kind of like that except like join that
cycle well now what's really interesting
I will that's interesting you ask that
what does tan inverse of X regular tan
inverse of X what does it look like in
relation to this and it sort of does
this rain I was basically asking yeah
okay what yeah that's exactly right so
therefore what must an inverse of 1 or X
look like if what you're doing is
putting this together with that from
getting this result the guy what's watch
is it there's going to be a reversal I
stopped giving example let's think about
this right let's pick a point like I'm
in a club quick pick a single 0 we can
give you but if I picked a value like
here right I need to add something to
that this is tan inverse of X I need to
add something to that to get up to the
black line right does that make sense
because the green plus whatever give me
the black box I need new color now the
point I'm pink happens to be pretty much
half way okay so I'm actually get it
interceptor what happens is I yeah Oh
dissen are you Sarah a heavier that from
you I what happened to the move to the
left as I moved to the left to war x
equals 0 0 it really grabs getting
smaller yes so the bluegrass got to make
up for it right so he has to sort of
climb up to there in exactly the same
way this guy climbs down whereas over
here because the green grass going on
the bluegrass gotta compensate right
it's like this give-and-take so he has
to come down at exactly the same rate
and it's going to do it x equals 4 y
equal 0 hasn't because as we established
this is also not function right you're
going to get the same Center shape yeah
okay yes yeah so that was just a point
of it now i watch your ever i asked you
to look at this before can you look back
at the question do I massage it away
from it look back here and you can see
the way it guides you through these blue
points which I said to you hate care you
like you guys have been graphing stuff
for ages right can you tell me something
useful batters and gave me this gestures
the question sort of hold your hands
alternate through a lot oh yeah you see
how it's structured a lot more for you
yeah it just says bigger right so you
can see by the way if they've just
handed to you this right it's at okay
this is not something we're assessing
here right now but they could easily
turn it into a question like I did where
I am assessing do you reckon dragons